Speaker 1: Listen, I continue to have this
very significant interest in Gavin Newsom as
a possible 2024 contender if indeed Joe Biden
were to not run for reelection. A Gavin Newsom
is not the uber progressive candidate that maybe
I would dream of, but you go to war with the army
you have, not the army you wish you had.
And Gavin Newsom is doing something very,
very important. He is accurately, concisely and
forcefully describing some of the obvious lies
that Republicans are telling and that voters
are falling for. And I have to tell you,
he's using critical language about Democrats,
but it is sort of tough love and Democrats are
terrible on messaging on so many issues. This
issue of crime in Democrat states and cities
is just a disaster. Last week I told you all
that in the Oklahoma gubernatorial debate.
It was correctly mentioned by candidate
Hofmeister that the rate of violent crime
in Oklahoma and Oklahoma City is higher than
the rate of violent crime in New York State
and New York City, respectively. And that is
absolutely the case. On MSNBC, Gavin Newsom,
interviewed by a seemingly smitten Alex Wagner,
who was just enthralled with what he was saying,
as she should be, because he is accurate when he
talks about this stuff saying Why aren't we doing
better on this? The numbers are on our side.
Speaker 3: It's not just a messaging problem.
A messaging problem that has persisted with
our party for years and years. Constantly
on the defensive. We allow these culture wars
to take shape, and we consistently are on the
back end of eight of the top ten states with the
highest murder rates. All the Republican states,
yes. How do Democrats not know? That fact is
really nine out of ten Georgia went for Biden,
but it's really a Republican state or at least
a red state, eight out of ten. And we're losing
that message. Crime is.
Speaker 1: Higher.
Speaker 3: As well as taxes here for the
average citizen in Texas, it's higher crime,
higher violent crime in property crimes than
in the state of California, 67% higher gun
death rate in Texas. Why don't we push back?
Speaker 1: I don't know the answer to that. Why
don't we push back? And remember, in my story
last week, we looked at some of this data. And
one of the things that you see, as I mentioned,
is that you've got Washington, D.C. with a very
high violent crime rate in 2019. And then also, we
have the numbers now for 2020. But you basically
have red states. It's Alaska, where violent crime
is high. New Mexico is a blue state. Tennessee red
state. Arkansas red state. Arizona wet Biden, but
basically a red state. Louisiana, Missouri. South
Carolina, South Dakota. You've got to get down
to Michigan before you get an actual another blue
state. And then it's Montana, Nevada, Oklahoma,
Alabama, Texas. And then you get to California
and then you're almost halfway done with the
list. You're almost at 25. Okay. It's similar
to the repeated claims that Republicans are good
for the economy. These are just lies. We're going
to lower the taxes and then encourage investment
and then just everything's going to be great and
the stock market will do well and unemployment
will be low. Folks, go to the numbers. The the
numbers aren't secret. If you have access to
Google, you can find the primary source numbers.
Overall, the economy does better by
the following metrics under Democrats.
Unemployment rate is lower. Job creation is
higher. Inflation is lower. GDP growth is higher.
Stock market returns are higher. There is many
others. Now, if you want to make a case that
even though the numbers are better when Democrats
are in the White House, it's actually thanks to
Republicans because of either a lag time which has
been debunked or because of who controls the house
mattering more. It's also been debunked. Or you
could. But you've got to start with the data, and
that's what the data is. I like what Gavin Newsom
is doing. I like what Gavin Newsom is saying.